cuando supieron que en realidad eran
gays literal desde que nací tuve un
novio en el jardín de infantes de verdad
jubilee presentar les presentamos a
siete chicos gays soy gay soy gay soy
gay soy gay soy gay soy gay soy gay no
está mintiendo si el grupo descubre
quién es el impostor se repartirá en la
cantidad de dinero entre ellos
si el impostor sobrevive se llevará todo
el dinero
el impostor
cuando salieron del clóset yo salí del
clóset cuando tenía 18 años 17
mi mamá de hecho me preguntó cuando se
lo iba a confesar básicamente tomó las
riendas y me preguntó eres gay y yo
estaba como yo lo hice un poco tarde lo
estuve escondiendo por un largo tiempo
tenía 23 esta fue como una ronda de
ansiedad el saber que casi no puedes
decir nada es muy poco tiempo así que yo
estaba como yo no voy a quedarme sin
hablar en esta ronda cuando tenía 17
revele mi sexualidad a mis hermanas a mi
mamá a los 21 porque encontré un anillo
para el pene en mi habitación y yo quedé
como
yo creo solo basándome en la apariencia
que el no encaja en el clásico
estereotipo ok
yo voté solo porque estaba debemos sacar
a alguien y mientras no sea yo
y
tramposos yo soy yo
muchas personas me dicen que yo no lleno
el estereotipo que todos esperan pero lo
que ellos creen que puede lucir un
hombre gay quizás el pelo largo y tal
vez la ropa no sé su estilo era muy
simple sin ofender
ok tengo una pregunta hipotética si
estuviésemos en un juego de béisbol
sería en el catcher o el pitcher yo soy
el catcher teacher ok
cualquiera de las dos diría que son yo
sería un cachet muy bien creo que la
pregunta más obvia es cuando supieron
ustedes que eran gays a qué edad literal
desde que nací tuve un novio en el
jardín de niños de verdad
su nombre era christopher y nos besamos
en el baño del jardín de niños y supe
que era mi historia fue sorpresivamente
durante el bachillerato por si nadie
sabe soy trans así que tuve dos
revelaciones realmente es difícil salir
del closet y decirle a tus padres pues
si técnicamente tuve que hacerlo tres
veces
primero como lesbiana porque así como
mujeres luego de eso me sentía muy
cómoda conmigo misma y entendí que era
una persona muy trans así que tuve que
revelar me otra vez y entendí que
realmente era gay demasiadas veces se se
ha revelado tres veces eso es algo raro
no es que lo juzgue pero no sé son
demasiadas veces eso no es común de ver
en mi caso estuve muy reprimido porque
mi papá era súper homofóbico y eso suele
pasar en la comunidad afroamericana sí
es cierto que son sumamente difíciles de
comprender para ellos pero llegué a un
punto de mi vida donde me di cuenta que
simplemente yo era distinto saben que
hice algo por mí mismo para no vivir con
ese miedo así que me mudé a san
francisco y eso me ayudó a aceptarme
mucho más saben es algo positivo gracias
por compartir las preguntas quién de
ustedes sufrió acoso en la secundaria
sólo por ser gay yo suprime mi
sexualidad es así
sufrí bullying desde que estaba en
primaria yo nunca dije que era gay pero
yo siempre me decían suenas como chicas
de seguro eres gay y todo era
deje que corrieron rumores sobre mi
sexualidad mientras lo negaba y eso me
molestaba pero ahora no me importa han
tenido sexo con una chica borracho
estado muy borracho
sólo puede estar con ella 15 segundos y
salir huyendo we fue algo muy incómodo
me fui a casa
me parece que es demasiado callado y
reservado no percibo esta vibra gay en
el rico no hablo mucho no me gusta
apostar sino que me parece que todavía
está en ese nivel superficial
vi la chaqueta de on the ground que
estaba usando y creo que es un truco de
su parte para que creamos que es fan de
beyonce así que creo que hay que
eliminarlo
buena suerte chicos soy yo muy bien me
gustaría saber cuál es su parte favorita
de nuestra comunidad son más tolerantes
sí sí y muy abiertos es muy bueno tener
una comunidad donde hay personas que han
pasado por tu situación
como somos solamente uno tenemos la
misma historia pero cada quien la vida y
el sentido de la moda y hablemos de
relaciones está bien quién está en una
hora yo no la verdad no sé lo que es y
qué tal los ex quién fue su último novio
él me ofrece dos o tres años pero rompí
con él porque aún estaba en el closet y
yo ya no entonces sé cómo que no tiene
los elementos digo en público tomar tu
mano y lo bueno de eso es que yo lo
ayudé a salir así que cuando me dijo que
no yo solo empecé a llorar
estaba en mi auto y fue como rayos guau
yo no
yo no tengo ex nunca jamás yo hablaba
con personas y eso pero fue la escuela
cuando se supone que empecé a sospechar
porque cada vez que hablábamos sobre
relaciones pasadas con algunos hombres
él no quería tocar el tema a profundidad
qué música les gusta escuchar se ensucia
mucho de la web y no
creo que solo tuvo éxito en ese álbum y
ya no
[Risas]
[Música]
siento que no me convence lo suficiente
una parte de mí está pensando que quizás
es solo una persona bien vestida
[Música]
estilo bellator nos vemos luego besos y
abrazos y ahora somos cuatro los últimos
cuatro levanten la mano si piensan que
el impostor sigue ahí
esperen un segundo ya que ya eliminaron
al impostor y no quiere seguir jugando
levanten la mano
o solo yo
entonces los demás quieren continuar si
está bien una ronda más perfecto y un
tatuaje de una chica en tu brazo sí que
te inspiró el lidiado con problemas de
depresión y autoestima y mi vida y
cuando paso por estas situaciones así es
como me siento solo me tengo a mí por
eso ella está como abrazando por
viviendo así por qué no un hombre creo
que si te gustan las mujeres te haces un
tatuaje de una actividad hacían en su
escuela muy buena presión deporte me
gustaba mucho las artes como yo sea
teatro musical
estuve en el coro me gustaba la danza y
un poco de fútbol pero sólo un poco
así es por un minuto sexual siempre
audición a va cada año para jugar fútbol
pero siempre existía cuando me tocaba
jugar en realidad es como jugar fútbol
todavía con ellos cuál es su tipo de
hombre cuando tienen que escoger me
gustan las personas pulcras en
apariencia pero en personalidad me
parece que deben ser tranquilas y
dóciles prefiero una personalidad de
beni bien hasta el vientre de ser una
persona
segura de sí misma que esté en su punto
más alto me han sorprendido muchas veces
y tengo un tipo de hombre de verdad en
serio no lo tengo soy de esos que sólo
le importa que conectes conmigo si
escuchamos la misma música si podemos
hacer actividades juntos cómo ir a
escalar a caminar todo eso es bueno no
me importa como luces ni quién sea sólo
para mí
se acerca el final qué nervios
[Música]
ustedes apestan todo sabe siento no me
convences levanten la mano si todavía
tienen dudas si quieren seguir jugando
de acuerdo a la verdad es que no tenía
ninguna duda sabía que todos ahí éramos
gays pero siendo egoístas sólo quería
que quedáramos dos bien volvemos al
chico con el que saliste que aún estaba
en el closet donde está ahora ustedes
volvieron luego de eso no hablaron mal
bueno a mí todavía él me gustaba pero yo
estaba como no puedo no puedo trate de
volver con él y estuvimos juntos por un
tiempo y pensé por qué hago esto y le
dije lo siento ya no me gustas más claro
entiendo cuando empezamos a esta ronda
pensé que podría preguntarle algo fuerte
y cuando respondió con esa firmeza me di
cuenta que no estaba mintiendo y pensé
oh cielos esa es la única pregunta que
le tenía creo que todos somos gay yo
también porque hacemos vídeos
vg
hay que bailar
[Risas]
bueno chicos cada uno voto por una
persona distinta sabía que ésta pasaría
cada uno tiene 20 segundos para
explicarnos por qué no debería salir del
juego bien
soy demasiado gay he hecho sexo oral a
otros
puede una persona de cero hacer esto
rojo
esto fue perfecto impresionante de
acuerdo soy gay
de verdad pues me costó un poco al
principio salir de mi escondite pero
luego de eso cambié mi punto de vista y
entendí que venimos en diferentes
colores estilos y diferentes ya saben en
todo así que no hay una forma correcta
de ser gay ni una forma correcta de ser
hetero especialmente en estos tiempos
donde queremos ser una representación de
un molde en el cual estemos conectados
todos juntos si hay alguien que nos está
viendo y se encuentra en la misma
situación puedo decir que lo entiendo es
genial ver esto y pensar bien puedo ser
yo mismo sin tener el miedo a ser
juzgado saben yo soy gay literalmente o
cual hetero que conozcas llevaría a su
cara pintada así solo vas a verme para
saberlo me gusta el glamour soy 100% yo
auténtico soy gay y me gustan los
hombres siempre los he amado no sé qué
más quieren que diga en este punto
lo sabía
lo siento adrián no estuvo tan mal pero
si me hablas a mí no técnicas de nada
son 125 para cada uno siga luces verde
expulsaron al impostor pero si se torna
roja el impostor está aún en la sala y
significa que partieron estoy bien me
siento seguro
miran videos el impostor por favor un
paso al frente
lo sabía porque la sexualidad demasiadas
veces en una de ellas bonitas hablas de
dinero no quiero hablar fue riesgoso
salir del closet rebelarme al grupo como
transgénero porque la mayoría de las
personas inválidas a nosotras en general
al primer momento muchas personas aún me
clasifican como lesbiana y puedo
mimetizarme con la comunidad gay de
hecho tuve un enorme presentimiento con
marcus desde el principio yo le creí un
100% mi radar gay heterosexual es
horrible son horribles creo que fue muy
importante hacer eso es bueno mostrar
que no hay un molde al cual encajar
incluso si te identificas con un grupo
específico eso no te define
nos llevamos el premio lo hicimos
martelly yo ahora tenemos que limpiar
esto verdad jubilee